how do you avoid that's something i just
thought of how do you avoid
normlessness and meaninglessness within
an anarchistic society because
if you're stripping back a lot of the
previous institutions
that people would have relied on to find
their sense of self and both me and you
were
big proponents of personal sovereignty
and upward agency and
yeah that sort of stuff but it you know
we have to concede that that isn't for
everybody
some people require those bigger
structures to hold themselves together
how would you propose supporting those
people
oh i don't support them i don't care
about them they're ballast they're they
don't really
[ __ ] list
they are we have brilliant ideas that
bring
yeah they bring nothing to well that's a
pejorative they bring nothing to the
table
um and you know if they were in uh
maybe iran they'd be radical jihadis and
if they're
in britain they're this and the american
they're this they don't really
think critically and that's fine but in
terms of what could be done for them i
mean
i i don't really know i can't empathize
with with them
whatever system works out like they will
just
obey whatever is the rules of the game
and they will
they will be able to kind of follow suit
and they'll watch the sitcoms and
you know and live this kind of docile
cow-like life
but i don't spend much time thinking
about them this is something that i
stress a lot with you know people who
are followers of mine they're like look
at all these people who are mindless
and i'm like how are these mindless
people a threat to you like they're
they're they're no they're like trees
like if are you like well we can't win
because there's all these trees it's
like what does that have to do with
anything
like any population an enormous percent
enormous percentage of it
is going to be with people who really
are in a very fundamental way mindless
who have no
kind of inner voice who are opposed or
incapable this is a big argument are
they imposed or incapable
of thinking critically and are you know
ed shall menken the great american kind
of cynic from the early 20th century
said has this great quote about the
average man does not want to be free he
simply wants to be safe
and i think you're seeing that a lot
more in britain sadly than in the states
nowadays
how they really want to be told what to
do
and kind of like just follow suit and i
know you're you know an entrepreneur
and kind of really trying to become much
more self-actualized and you've talked
to me about this how this is something
that you find uh
it's not only frustrating to be
surrounded by it
but it's also maddening in the sense of
like how are you like this
like we are so blessed with so many
opportunities
and you just want to watch you know a
celebrity big brother
and whatnot and and just you know have a
pint and then go to bed
not there's anything wrong with that but
that's their highest that's their
highest desperation i i love
trashy tv i love having a drink or
whatever but
there there's a time and a place for
both my
tragedy the tragedy that i see is people
doing that
every decade for three or four in a row
that to me is
is a life wasted um yes and it's their
life to waste
but it still doesn't mean necessarily
that i need to
be an advocate or supportive in any way
of it i wonder
whether it's a particularly british
phenomenon
i can't speak for other people other
nations maybe some of the people can let
us know in the comments from where
they're from and and
how they find their culture with regards
to this total lack of personal
sovereignty and upward mobility
uh an ability to do anything sort of uh
laterally as well to think like okay
here is the path that i'm on let's just
see what happens if i take a big left
turn
let's just see maybe maybe it totally
wrecks everything but maybe it's
actually not that bad
and um i've had this idea for a while
that it's because we're water locked
because we're quite a small nation
because the weather's quite bad the even
if you look at
excuses no so this is me this is me
saying what are the things that feed it
into the british culture
i know but these are right but you know
what i mean like we'll all you'll always
find a reason not to achieve
or not to hope or not to think
critically there's no shortage ever
do you see this can you imagine like
someone saying like the reason i don't
want to
aspire to you know run my own like
toffee shop
is because of the weather i get that but
we're mimetic creatures right
mimetic desire is a big thing and i feel
like in a place that had more
there was more cosmopolitan for instance
is one thing if you had a bigger country
with more
international visitors you may have more
people coming and going that would
actually be able to broaden your mindset
if you had slightly better weather
people would be able to do
more things outside of just like at the
moment it's
dark at 8 00 a.m and 4 30 p.m
and it's raining all day every day there
isn't a massive amount of stuff that you
can do
if you could perhaps that would broaden
your perspective maybe i don't just need
to go
pub netflix work pub netflix work
yeah you're not going to tell me
london's not international enough i mean
this this is
it it's really and there's so i love
british culture
and in fact i've been to the uk once and
i did not have a good time and i
interviewed arya
she was from the band the slits old
school punk band johnny rotten's
um step-daughter and she said yeah i'm
not gonna do her accent she had this
jamaican accent she passed away not that
long ago
and she said yeah we all hated london
we couldn't wait to get the [ __ ] out of
there her words and she's like no wonder
you didn't have a good time
and to me the the the
best thing about uh britain
is how it you know you know obviously
the british empire i'm sure something
has very mixed
uh emotional people residents of people
from england
but the idea that you had all these
countries
from all over the world under the sway
of the queen
or whoever the king was at the time and
you imported elements to it to britain
and it made this kind of cosmopolitan
culture like tea time
you know coming from japan and and i
mean music
and the british museum are you kidding
me it's just
it's just an amazing miracle of
civilization so
i i i don't buy into that at all just
because it's
if the rain is going to stop you from
like becoming a better person
it's not the rain it's a good point i
think
i might be slightly jaded because i'm in
newcastle which is the last city before
scotland
and there is a very much a small town
mentality
as soon as you get pretty much out of
london you
go to even the biggest cities manchester
birmingham you have people
like born live die well aren't those
kind of like
like [ __ ] i mean aren't they like
really kind of
like relics of what they used to be and
that they're kind of very depressing
used to be much more industrial
uh and this kind of economic okay i
think that's most of the uk man like
you know yeah really what have we got we
it's not like we have natural resources
the only thing that we can export is our
intellect and our accent
like those those are the two biggest
exports that we have
my friend was is a mick ronson's
daughter he was bowie's guitarist and he
was from hull
and she's like you don't understand like
what it's like going there she's like
it's
it's like maybe it's like detroit but
it's really like you go
you know when the sex pistols sing about
there's no future there are those places
in the uk and you'd obviously know it's
better than i do
where you grow up and it's in those
cases the weather does matter
because if everything's run down and the
weather sucks and it's dark
it's very hard to see sunshine and
emotional levels so i'll
i'll accept that
you